[Musique]
tous les cinq ans on publie un bilan de
santé des parcs nationaux du québec
un peu comme les humains qui vont chez
le médecin les parcs passe une batterie
de tests ils sont scrutées de près et
quand on détecte un problème on peut
ainsi mieux intervenir pour protéger ces
précieux espace diagnostic du parc
national de plaisance en outaouais
[Musique]
octobre au parc national de plaisance
une bande de 28 kilomètres carrés le
long de la rivière des outaouais
composées aux deux tiers de milieux
humides et de marais un endroit de
prédilection pour les oiseaux migrateurs
la faune et la flore
ils sont exceptionnels pas surprenant
que des dizaines de milliers de
visiteurs s'y rendent chaque année le
parc c'est la paix c'est aussi la
tranquillité mais c'est aussi toute la
nature qui nous entoure
jean-marc purell parcours des sentiers
du parc national de plaisance depuis une
quinzaine d'années le parc et son refuge
ça m'amène à rester en forme à voir la
vie d'une façon agréable
tout simplement parce que je
continuellement entouré de beautés si
jean-marc garde la forme son parc lui
excellent santé
pour connaître et assurer la santé d'un
parc
les responsables de sa conservation
doivent faire régulièrement un vide dans
ce coin l'honore la bresse ain ce matin
à plaisance
on réalise l'inventaire des oiseaux
migrateurs
marc cerrone de nos nombreux indicateurs
qu'on fait pour suivre un peu différents
aspects du parc
l'idée c'est de voir s'il ya des
changements et des petits drapeaux qui
se lève avec le temps au niveau des
populations donc sur le coup c'est ça
nous dit pas grand chose mais c'est avec
le temps qu on voit le drapeau s'est
levé puis voit pas la nouvelle double
pour savoir ce qui se passe sur leur
territoire les responsables des 27 parcs
nationaux du québec doit faire plus que
l'inventaire d'oiseaux par exemple il
vérifie la qualité de l'eau de l'air
la diversité des écosystèmes
l'interaction entre les humains et la
nature
ils définissent ensuite des priorités de
conservation à plaisance l'un des
principaux défis sera la survie de la
forêt
récemment on a constaté look elle même
que la phase du parc va changer
drastiquement cours des prochaines
années
l'un des ennemis c'est l'agrile du frêne
un insecte qui fait le bonheur des pics
bois mais qui met en péril
25% des arbres du parc les relevés de
l'année dernière disait vrai ça va pas
le professeur loren z6 et son groupe de
chercheurs de l'institut des sciences de
la forêt tempérée s'intéresse à cet
insecte ravageur et envoie en voit le
bout de la larve irréparable et les
plier en deux se freine comme tous ceux
qui l'entourent et condamné aujourd'hui
on a confirmé hors de tout doute que
l'insecte il est bien là il est bien
actif sur plusieurs arts on retrouve des
larves cette forêt leur risque de mourir
totalement d'ici un an ou deux
[Musique]
l'agrile est un ennemi minuscule qui
dévorent les frais sous les corses sans
que les visiteurs ne s'en rende compte
mais d'autres prédateurs s'attaque aussi
à la forêt de fresnes et il est beaucoup
moins subtile juste dans l'endroit au
monde il ya à peu près six ou sept
arbres qui sont comme beck son mac
tout simplement ils ont été grugés
complètement et sausset d'amd dans les
derniers six jours j'ai lu la semaine
dernière puis césar mais encore leur dos
le coupable c'est le castor
il est partout dans les marais dans les
forêts et même au beau milieu des
sentiers on ne l'a plus forte
concentration que les castors maintenant
au québec en territoire inexploité
on évalue sur un petit territoire d'à
peu près 10 kilomètres carrés de terre
ferme et fort elle a une population d'au
dessus de 500 k stores se sait plus de
108 active c'est énorme
[Musique]
dont vaud des chaînes se faire abattre
des pailles et blanc on voit des érables
à sucre
on assiste en espèces d'abattage
anarchique de notre rêve alors nous ça
nous inquiète on doit intervenir à ce
moment là parmi les solutions
le parc a choisi de protéger certains
arbres en particulier nous micocouliers
le font parce qu'ils sont en danger
parce qu'en surpopulation castor les
castors et gruge tous des populations
d'arbres a comme cela on va les protéger
avec des grillages tout simplement fait
qu'on ait plusieurs centaines d'arbres
grillage un peu partout par qu'on peut
pas tout grillagée mais on choisit nos
notices potes là qu'on veut préserver
comme ça dans des castors on aura beau
protéger quelques arbres à terme la
perte des populations de fresnes ravagé
par la grille et les castors va
provoquer l'apparition de trous dans la
canopée et poser un sérieux problème
[Musique]
oui c'est inquiétant pour l'intégrité
écologique du parc donc il faut agir
pour essayer de boucher le trou que
cette essence non le réseau écologique
naturelle de duparc longue que créer ces
forêts là à proximité des milieux
humides c'est nous avons des remparts
contre les plantes exotiques
envahissantes conte à proximité puis
attendre jusque là lumière se fasse par
la disparition de la canopée introverti
de la couverture forestière donc sur
cette période du rempart ça nous
inquiète aussi beaucoup
[Musique]
et voici l'envahisseur
le roseau commun qu'on appelle aussi
phragmites cette plante exotique a déjà
fait son apparition aux parcs et aux
craintes d'une percée majeure le roseau
commun c'est une plante cantal rendre
dans les menus mais le manteau au parc
créé des massifs infranchissable il n'y
a plus rien d'autre qui poussent ils
prennent toute la place donc cette
plante l'on va voir propriété d'assécher
des musulmans donc c'est toute la
biodiversité du territoire
maclean's part et les roseaux sont
entrés dans le parc national de
plaisance en provenance des ruisseaux et
des fossés qui bordent les routes en
périphérie la lutte contre cet
envahisseur s'annonce difficile mais
elle n'est pas perdu d'avancé
quand on est dans un parc comme le parc
national de plaisance vraiment au coeur
des zones urbaines et agricoles les
problématiques sont arrivent de
l'extérieur avec nous on a beau
travailler s'il se passe rien
l'extérieur on sait comme des coups
d'épée dans l'eau
ça va continuer à rentrer au parc donc
on n'a pas le choix d'aller voir nos
voisins et l'appel a été entendu
[Musique]
la petite municipalité voisine de canton
de l'ocab heures a pris le taureau par
les cornes en collaboration avec le
ministère des transports du québec
elle s'attaque aux îlots de roseaux le
long des routes en périphérie du parc
[Musique]
on sait que le parc de plaisance a un
attrait touristique
c'est très important d'avoir son paysage
c'est une qualité de vie qui est apporté
à notre région et donc c'est important
de pouvoir le le protéger aussi parce
que protéger le parc tout seul ce ne
sera pas suffisant il faut étendre aux
abords créé une bulle autour du parc
pour empêcher un envahissement futur du
parc par le roseau le cas de plaisance
n'est vraiment pas unique
pour bien des parcs nationaux du québec
les principales menaces à la santé des
écosystèmes viennent aussi de la
périphérie les activités humaines autour
de ces territoires sont devenues un
enjeu majeur de conservation de la
biodiversité sur lesquels les
responsables des parcs ont souvent plus
d'emprise
mais reste qu'au parc national de
plaisance tout est loin d'alema le
mariage entre visiteurs et protection du
milieu naturel fonctionne les principaux
indicateurs phonique sont stables ou en
croissance
on y retrouve près de 260 espèces
d'oiseaux même la grue du canada y
effectue un retour les amphibiens sont
aussi au rendez vous et la vedette est
sans contredit la tortue serpentine
l'emblème officiel du parti
on peut l'observer en grand nombre en
juin au moment de la porte de bonnes
nouvelles et des défis qui nécessitent
de réfléchir et de passer à l'action
[Musique]
il ya de l'espoir pour le parc puis 50
c'est de tout simplement sensibiliser
plus possible les gens réalité qui
l'entouré puis à partir de demain ils
vont agir on doit avoir une attitude
j'irai peut-être un petit peu zen
travailler correctement comprendre les
impacts seuil et ne pas répéter les
erreurs du passé et c'est passe à
travers la tempête
le parc national de plaisance et en
santé il va bien puis on sent que la
santé dans sa périphérique est très
importante
ben ça entraîne aussi de l'être encore
plus par l'implication du milieu autour
de nous ça augure bien on est super un
courage et je pense que parce qu'il est
en de bonnes mains
[Musique]